we start in the u.s city of nashville in
the state of tennessee where an
explosion has caused widespread damage
a parked vehicle blew up in the downtown
area eyewitnesses say they heard a loud
boom early on christmas morning
followed by black smoke and billowing
flames the blast blew out of windows and
damaged surrounding buildings
police say they believe the explosion
was intentional emergency crews are at
the scene
well joining us now on the phone from
nashville is betsy williams whose
apartment is directly opposite where the
vehicle exploded
welcome to dw betsy when did all this
start
thank you this started about 4 30 this
morning
central time and we heard gunshots
uh out on the street and they were very
loud and
uh you know that we're we're in a big
entertainment district and
and so uh we were concerned about that
but then
it happened again and so a few minutes
later so we called
911 and then
the gunshots happened for the third time
and it was if they were very loud and it
was like it was
from an automatic weapon but you know
thinking back on that now
were they really firing the shots or was
that some recording that they were
uh had out there i don't know but
then after the third series of gunshots
we heard we noticed an rv
a white rv parked right across the
street
and uh and coming from the rv was a
computerized
voice message saying evacuate now
evacuate now this vehicle has a bomb
it will explode evacuate now
and so this went on for about 30 minutes
and we were
are about that you know it's not like i
was sitting there looking at my phone
trying to figure out what the time was
on this but
um it was it was about 30 minutes that
that happened
and then it started on a countdown where
it said
this vehicle will explode in 15 minutes
and then in 14 minutes and then so well
you know we started really gathering our
things up i got my cat
in her carrier i got my son who was
staying in another apartment that was
also overlooking second avenue and we
were all
very concerned about all this and so and
then my
85 year old sister was staying in
another apartment
that was on the other side of the
building on the back side overlooking
the river
and so we all went down got in the car
and left and we went across the bridge
over to lp field um and
our nissan stadium i keep calling it lp
field it's nissan stadium
and we went over there and sat there for
about 20 minutes
and you could still see your apartment
from where you were at
we could see the back of it yes we
couldn't see the second avenue side we
could see first avenue which those
streets were in parallel to one another
so
um so then we went back
i said well you know clearly this is
nothing's going to happen so
a drove back came back down 2nd avenue
headed north on 2nd avenue and got to
broadway
which is our main thoroughfare through
our entertainment district in nashville
where all the honky tonks are
and um and i was sitting there because
the police did have 2nd avenue blocked
off and i and was trying to decide am i
going to go park car
go back you know and um and and it
exploded and the fireball from that
thing
rose up past the top of the att property
that was sitting there
and and you know i've seen all these
other pictures since
and it completely blew out the entire
front
of the three to four buildings that are
just north of
ours blew out all of our windows blew
out windows
on the back side of the building the
riverside of the building
blew all of those windows out and also
blew windows out
on third avenue which was a block over
so
the windows the windows in your building
were blown out so
what would have happened if you'd have
stayed i would have been killed
i would have been killed i would have
been at the very least
severely injured but because i was
sitting right there i mean we were
we raised the window so we could really
clearly hear
what the rv was saying and to make sure
it was coming from the rv
and it was indeed coming from the rv and
um
and i don't know if you've what pictures
you've seen there was a white car
that was parked a couple of spaces
behind
that rv which was of course destroyed
in the explosion but there was nothing
left of that rv
it it went i mean it completely exploded
i mean i'm sure they'll find
remnants of it but yeah and so the other
thing
you you say was it was outside the att
building i mean
is there anything in that in that area
that could have been a target
i don't i don't know i know that there
are some communications equipment
that there is communications equipment
for that att
has in that building but i don't know
how because they actually moved their
headquarters to what we call the batman
building
in 1996 i think but they still
retain that building over there and i
know that they do have some equipment in
it
it doesn't have any windows they don't
have many people who work over there
you know it's a it's a fairly desolate
uh building
in terms of pedestrian activity and
and all of this and like i said no
windows and
that van that's not van the rv
the was was parked right
there in front of that building and this
rv was an
older model but it was in pristine
condition i mean in terms of looking at
it it was
white white and not any dirt on it
didn't have any markings on it that i
could see when i looked at it
but you know i also i didn't take a
photograph
and why i didn't take a photograph of it
i don't know
because it was just sitting in the
street it's just it's just just a car
you want to know it was going to
go up in flames how long did it take how
long did it take for police to arrive
uh well the police got there fairly
quickly after we
after the 9-1-1 call you know they got
there
they got there pretty quickly they sent
they sent uh
two cars down there i mean you know
it's gunshots and then they got out and
heard that thing
and when that thing started going off
you know we didn't go down we weren't
trying to but because what if there'd
been a gunman on the street
you know so so because that could have
been very
what the scenario was that that was the
one that made the most sense to us
we didn't want to draw attention to our
building up there
you know because i didn't want to get
shot
well we're very glad you're safe and and
thank you so much for talking to us
here at ddw thank you thank you so much
thank you for checking on us okay bye
that's uh betsy
williams and nashville resident
you